John good morning how are you I'm doing
good thanks Dan you've done a great job
hey you know what as a friend I I can
say that but as a friend I would be
critical with you I I think you've done
an exceptional job so congratulations on
just being yourself in the booth well I
appreciate that and you know what I hope
it comes across I'm having fun because
if I wasn't having fun that I'd be
worried about now not being positive now
it's your job to return the favor i gave
you a compliment just to get a
compliment return well normally you know
i would do that right away but again I I
want to wait just a little bit so that
people don't think it's just a fake
compliment you've given me but as you
know i mean i set my DVR my TV and TV
are I record everything you do so it's
really the greatest comp I don't do that
for anybody else but I record everything
that you do and matter of fact I mean I
got a lot of watching to do when I get
home from the road well that's just add
people don't realize that you record
everything you don't watch it you just
record it but um yes well someday I'm
going to get a chance to really enjoy it
and watch it and I heard you last night
you said you'd like to ride in a blimp I
have connections with the directv blimp
pilot and if you would like for me to
hook that up after the postseason I'd be
more than happy to do that for you yeah
I mean I gotta do it I gotta do it one
one one time just experience you know
what that's like okay I'll take you up
on that for sure all right um Ariel
Arrieta was dealing last night and I I
was wondering how long Joe Maddon's
going to stay with him obviously gave up
the hit then lost the shutout and it
felt like that madden was looking for an
excuse to get him out there did it feel
like a quicker hook to you with Arrieta
last night not really is one of those
games you know he was getting away with
look he throws a lot of pitches at move
but he was getting away with what i
would call maybe the Indians just his
his wildness was caught
costing them the ability to get locked
in and look Jake for whatever reason in
the second half has thrown a lot more
pitches to get results so even if he
hadn't given up a hit I don't think
Madden was going to allow him to go much
deeper is this the way he's been with
his bullpen he's not taking any chances
and certainly validating a win would
have been the priority instead of
letting somebody get something special
in the postseason it was a good sign
though for Jake to get through that game
not give up any runs he gets a couple
spurts where he loses command of a
fastball we saw that with a couple walks
in the first afterwards he made enough
pitches and certainly getting the lead
for the Cubs is huge I thought the
biggest play in the first inning was the
fact that a cough place and the relay
man was was missed because bryant would
have been easily out of him so the Cubs
took advantage of that we're aggressive
got on the board and I thought there was
a huge moment in the game I call
swarmers availability now playing in the
field what do you do with your Joe
Maddon gosh I mean look a lot of times a
manager and an organization they try to
push buttons and some things work some
things don't I thought this was a huge
huge gamble that has definitely paid off
I didn't think there was any chance that
a guy could be five months out yet alone
John even have any experience you know
it's one thing to have ten years in the
game and be a professional hitter know
that you can handle the circumstances uh
this is none of the case I mean this is
unbelievable to think that a kid with
this talent they think that highly of
them they wouldn't even consider a trade
for incredible pieces they can get back
and and look ed ates they were probably
looking at two maybe three swings that
could affect the game well it's affected
the game so much that I think the
question you raised is a good one and
they're going to be pondering it I
wouldn't be surprised if he plays one
game you know even this game at home
friday a matchup against tomlin is a lot
more conducive and a ground ball pitcher
in hendrix then necessarily facing
Kluber is not a great as matchup and of
course you know then you have more of a
flyball pitcher and Lackey so I look I
I'm still I shakin my head I give him
all the respect of all the props in the
world for doing this and being prepared
mentally to deal with something that
could have easily failed could have
easily been five out of six strikeouts
and no one would have thought anything
different other than what were the Cubs
thinking instead they're talking about
it like I am and just marveling and my
career never standing like it John
Smoltz major league baseball on phonics
game three coming up on friday night how
do you approach this as an analyst any
different from the regular season well I
explain it like this i mean the regular
season as a player i want to win every
game i did i was competitive as you can
be and but i never approached a
postseason game I never approached a
regular season game like a postseason
game I poured every energy I had every
attention to detail I love the
postseason as a player I just couldn't
pitch 35 postseason games and as an
analyst the same thing in the regular
season game I want to be the best they
can but you can't make a regular season
game a postseason game the crowd knows
it everybody knows it and it is what it
is you know the matchup may or may not
be what you can get when you get to the
postseason so the attention to detail
the emotions and everything that I've
been through prepares me I think about
as well I don't think I'll be surprised
and I really have a central goal and
that's to take the game hopefully to a
viewer in a way where the day the game's
not easy be explained why the moment can
create such a an adverse reaction for a
player or a player a player not making a
play or just the game getting too fast
because I've seen it and I've lived it
and and for me I really am having a
great time I enjoyed this time of the
year about as much as any other thing
that I've been through and and hopefully
will continue to view it that way how
are you with criticism as an
analyst as opposed to a player you know
it's interesting because I'm a flip side
when I was a player everybody at some
point on the regular season get
critiqued you get criticized it's not as
big a deal but when you get criticized
in the postseason you're a little bit
more sensitive to it because the
emotions are higher and as a younger
player I probably listened a little too
much to some of those stuff and would
call in a talk radio here or two but and
then after that you realize it's not
that big a deal when you can feel that
the pressure and the magnitude of this
moment everybody's watching and so I'm
sure in my lover long career i'm going
to have as a broadcaster someone's going
to be offended by something i say but
it's never intentional and it's not
because you don't understand how hard
the game is so i don't care about the
criticism I'll actually warrant it and
want to begin be as good as I can but I
take the criticism from the people that
I value will help me be a better
broadcaster not necessarily you know
because I'm not on any social networking
and not necessarily just how people
think outside the world but look I I
love the fact that people care at this
time and people are passionate about
their team but I can tell you this
they're so used to their home broadcasts
right I'm gonna get to this level in the
national level they really do assume
that you're pulling for somebody are you
rooting for somebody that can't be
farther from the truth but the reality
is they I think what makes a good
broadcast as if fifty percent think
you're rooting for the other team
because when you get down to the last
two teams they are listening to a
national broadcast the team that and
they haven't heard and haven't followed
their team so they're not used to
hearing a broadcast team talk about the
other team yeah always used to them
talking about their own team well all
you need to do is ask Joe Buck about it
because joe get joe gets wrapped because
it always feels like he's rooting for or
against somebody now you mentioned
passion we didn't know if you could slip
in passion bucket a legendary phrase on
this program but you know like the Cubs
fans passion bucket is over overflowing
or you know game three yeah it's good
it'll get in there friday passion
buckets in their passion bucket you can
at some point during the game you're
gonna you're gonna hear the passion
bucket because they didn't hear it in
the Hall of Fame speech that I think you
promised remember you know what happened
there there's two things that happened
there first of all I've never read a
speech and that was the first one that I
read in my life and I got a little
nervous and I got off scrip a couple
times I forgot Ted Turner and i forgot
the passion bucket so you bought and I
did okay I did okay tried to make it
right in the postgame interview comments
um when they asked me those things but
yeah I did I got off script a little bit
alright so friday night now i'm going to
watch that you're going to throw in
passion bucket with Game three and
regular yeah I'm gonna put that down as
one of the star-nosed or what you're
looking forward to tonight in the game
exactly yeah somehow more passion bucket
yeah exactly i think that that's
definitely gonna make it I like it uh so
safe travels great talk to you John and
well done I appreciate that thing that's
Johnny Smoltz Major League Baseball on
Fox the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience